another day of protests in Iran another
day the regime's forces cracked down on
the masses demanding fundamental human
rights it's unclear exactly how many
take to the streets each day or where
they do it but even with the smallest
acts of Civil Disobedience they risk
their freedom their lies the desire for
change has grown bigger than the fear
and the movement has become the greatest
challenge to the authoritarian theocracy
since the Islamic revolution in 1979.
the people versus the state
so far Iranian authorities are holding
firm
that's the elite revolutionary guards
who control most of the economy and
security
and the clerics led by supreme leader
Ayatollah who make the rules
officials say the unrest is the work of
foreign agents especially the US and
Israel
why did the enemies why did America and
the Zionist regime conspire against our
nation and our Revolution and create
these riots as the supreme leader said
our country is advancing and the enemies
don't want our country to make progress
for their part protesters aren't just
angry about one policy they're rejecting
the whole regime a regime that has not
tried to accommodate them instead the
head of the Revolutionary guards has
tried to play Down the level of public
discontent
we are telling our youth the minority
who have been deceived to stop Wicked
acts today is the end of the riots don't
go to the streets anymore
foreign
but unlike in protests of the past this
time around students have been joined by
working class crowds a broad-based loose
Alliance that threatens the regime's
base of support
burning hijabs and attacking police
stations rejecting the authority of the
security services and the religious
rules of the clerics
hello everyone the challenge for Iran's
rulers is to manage the protests without
setting off more unrest that's a
difficult balance and it's one that it's
far from clear the government is capable
of
well let's extend that question to
kamran Martin he's a lecturer on
international relations at the
University of Essex in the UK Mr Martin
welcome to the day so can Iran's rulers
manage the protests without fueling them
uh hi um I'm actually at University of
Sussex um just to correct that I mean
the Iranian regime is facing a really
difficult task because the nature of the
process is different and their
capacities seem to have been exhausted
the the protests are different because a
um it's it's LED and instigated by women
which is a bit difficult for the regime
to sell to its base is social base which
is increasingly narrowing that these are
you know foreign plots and these are
connected to the to outside the world
and the protesters are unarmed and the
protests are also extremely dispersed
geographically in many places as
simultaneously the protesters have kind
of designed or kind of come up with
their own Innovative modes of protests
usually small scale in different
neighborhoods at the same time which
means that security forces have to be
kind of strained and dispersed in
different places at the same time and
most importantly the protests have gone
on for seven weeks and this means that
the the offices on the ground are
exhausted the human resources of the
security forces seems to have reached
its its limits so at this rate if it
continues it's not entirely clear that
what the regime is is able to do and
there is there are signs of a bit of
confusion within the state they try to
um kind of
um uh scare people off the streets by
unleashing excessive violence in the
periphery of Iran in ethnic minority
regions such as baluchistan where in one
single day in the city of zahidan up to
90 people were Massacre but even this
hasn't deterred the protests protesters
and therefore it doesn't seem that the
regime has many new ideas to to bring to
the to the protest and and they they
seem to be continuing as they did today
and so how vulnerable sorry to jump in
there but how vulnerable is the regime
after these seven weeks
I think the vulnerability seems to kind
of increase by the day and um I mean we
saw today in carrage near Tehran people
actually defended themselves against the
violence of the secretive forces and
according to the state media one besiege
kind of militia related to irgc was
killed and there were videos of security
forces cars being set to light and so on
so people are increasingly actually
defending themselves not simply
resisting and this also adds to the
pressure on the security forces so the
vulnerability seems to go um kind of go
up increase by day do you think we'll
see the violent spiral out of control
well I mean at this rate if if the
regime continues the kind of violence it
has Unleashed up to now and if it
increases it and as if people continue
to defending themselves with kind of uh
makeshift weapons or simply defending
themselves with whatever they have there
is a possibility that there will be more
casualties
um but I think the regime is also aware
that excessive violence in the major
Urban centers such as Tehran or other
big cities
can actually make things worse and kind
of increase the scale of the problem
they are facing so much depends on what
sort of measures the regime is taking in
the coming days and weeks but one thing
is clear that Islamic Republic of Iran
is not used to compromise with internal
opposition and that is the kind of
Aquila seal so to speak yeah Western
governments are unified in their
condemnation of Iran and the response to
the protests but what leverage do
outside actors have on what Iran does to
its people and does Iran care
well I think actually the symbolism of
Iranian States isolation in
international bodies and institutions is
quite important which is why we recently
saw that Iranian foreign Ministry wrote
to European countries warning them
against
um taking measures against its
um kind of diplomatic centers or or you
know the idea that you might put
Revolution on its list of kind of
sanction entities has quite
reverberated within Iran
um you know expelling Iran from U.N
bodies such as the one overseeing the
human rights of women's rights these are
actually measures which are important in
the sense that it gives support and
solidarity with Iranian people and they
would feel that they are not alone in
this struggle for basic human rights and
and the kind of change of regimes into a
more democratic one
um so yeah there are certain level of
Leverage which outside world has against
the Islamic Republic now not too long
ago the talks on renewing the Iranian
nuclear deal looked like they were
making some progress is all that on hold
now because of the protests
I think the prospects actually are
extremely slim now for multiple reasons
um the midterm elections the United
States is very close and the signs
indicate that action Republicans might
take control of the house and that would
make actually a deal by the Biden
Administration with Iran especially
under the circumstances we have now
given the internal protest which
increasingly by the way protesters
themselves call it a revolution there is
this slogan that is no longer a protest
it's a revolution so it will be very
costly politically for Biden to come and
compromise with Iranian regime on the
other hand
I don't think a deal actually would
change much inside Iran in terms of you
know economic benefits of it would would
actually likely to re-inflame the
process rather than stop it on the other
hand we have a change of government in
Israel which might actually affect the
whole process even more exactly kamran
Martin of the University of Sussex not
Essex excuses for that
but no problem thank you